hey guys how's it going today we're
gonna be making pumpkin bread and
pumpkin bread is one of my most favorite
things ever so I'm going to try to the
hardest of my cooking abilities to not
mess this up because I'm really looking
forward to eating it I found this recipe
online I'll put a link in the
description the original recipe is from
her grandmother's recipe box so as you
can see it clearly looks legit this
recipe makes two loaves and I only have
one pan so I just ordered Amazon Prime
now so hopefully it'll be here within
the next half hour so it'll be able to
make two loaves in the bowl of an
electric mixer oh gosh
Jana got a hand mixer and I haven't used
it yet this is gonna be exciting I would
use a blender but I don't feel like
cleaning it I guess I'm just gonna use
this I really should roll up my bowls
went so the first thing you have to do
is whisk together the flour salt baking
powder and baking soda and spices Oh
so 2 cups of all-purpose flour 1 cup 2
cup 1/2 teaspoon of salt so if I was a
teaspoon I'd be somewhere around
I guess that much I needed I knew see
still that's a tip I actually thought
this was a lot less I've been doing a
lot of things wrong so we're gonna put a
little more in I apologize to those who
are here for lack of measuring measuring
measuring measuring tell me how you say
it
because every way that I say it you guys
yell at me and I already messed up
because it said it was 1/2 teaspoon of
salt not a full teaspoon so things are
clearly already going well it's like the
directions are in front of me but the
things that I'm putting in it's just
let's just not even talk about it
1 teaspoon of ground nutmeg oh gosh it's
quite apparent that I've never used any
of these spices before because they are
all brand new all of this measuring is
making me feel funny
okay two cups of sugar
one two and just a little extra because
I'm sweet like that I didn't bring it my
oven this is all looking good one
teaspoon of baking soda 1/2 teaspoon
baking powder
I should probably melt my butter so two
large eggs one going in something that
really makes me uncomfortable is when I
find an egg it was a feather on it I
mean I know where the egg comes from I
know it's just something about seeing
the feather really just puts it all into
perspective okay how does this thing
work I'm just gonna push the button
right
Doughboy this is my first time using a
hand mixer
may you get out of control pass it in
the Potter which I have nicely melted
this is so freaking violent
put this pumpkin in wear white shirt
Thanks dangerous
yeah I don't even think this is in there
all the way well either way it worked
it's always good to taste it before you
bake it in case it tastes like garbage
and at that point I'm gonna bake it
anyway oh wow that's really good their
degrees and dust with flour I don't like
that sampling game is all right from
here yep just got the message
Alexa set a timer for 65 minutes one
hour and five minutes starting now
here we go cheers to the freakin weekend
I'll see you guys in one hour in five
minutes on the dot oh gosh Alexa cancel
all of my alarms cancel all of my
lawyers cancel them all hey look I
tested this cake so many times it has so
many holes all through it I think it's I
think it's looking pretty good so I'm
probably just gonna let this cool down
and then I'm gonna cut it up and see
what we've got
I don't know if I should put it on a
cooling rack now or if I should wait
maybe I'll put it on a cooling rack just
to be safe or maybe I'll wait
or maybe I'll put hmm the pumpkin loaf
is done and cold actually it's still
really warm it's very warm actually
we're gonna cut into this and take a
taste I'll just cut it in the middle
yeah it's really really soft
my favorite pumpkin bread is if you guys
are East Coasters this place called Bob
Evans they have the best pumpkin bread
ever so hopefully this somewhat stands
up to it
oh wow this is really good it may
actually be better than Bob Evans
I wanna on the front bar alone well
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this video next
week I'm going to have a cooking video
every day it's gonna be a Halloween
themed video so stay tuned for that I'm
pretty excited and the meantime you guys
want to make this recipe it's actually
pretty good
excuse you
pumpkin is actually really good for dogs
too so you have a dog that has some
liquid poos give them some pumpkin it
makes their not so liquid anymore
I'll see you guys in the next video bye
3 packaging
one of my favorite accessories for the
previous GoPros was the blackout housing
so basically would make your previous
silver versions into a beautiful matte
black just like this